hello everyone this is emily here from
audio science review i have a
another power amplifier review for you
hopefully it'll do well so that we get
out of this rod we're in where i keep
testing stuff that doesn't perform uh
today's product is uh by audiophonics
audiophonics is a e-teller in in france
that mostly sells other companies stuff
but occasionally also builds their own
uh designs
and that's the case in here with this
hpa s400 et
is based on a module from a company
called purify um
purify is a
successor from a company called hypex
which is still around bruno putzi's uh
if you haven't seen him it's one of the
top audio designers that we have when it
comes to amplification and and some
extended speakers
and he contracted that with hypex and
designed their amplifiers for them which
are extremely high performance class d
the first class status was really done
right
and uh he then moved on and and did a
startup that called purify and
uh produced this module the one et
um 400a
purify sorry the audiophonics amp uh
cost about 1490 euros uh which
translates today's exchange rate about
1600 although i'm told that that
includes vat so if you're importing it
from there to us
you can take out the vit but then you
gotta pay shipping for it
excuse me
um it's a very slick looking amplifier
which i really like a lot of times these
uh
amplifiers even though they're quite
small you can see them over here they
wind up being put in large boxes i might
as well take advantage of the size and
weight advance
benefits of class d and put them in a
slick case and you can see it over here
very nice looking case
the back is also very nice looking these
binding posts you can't quite see them
over here from the dead-on angle but
they're quite nice actually you can see
them down here in the
tear down
nice carbon fiber kind of look to them
and very strong shaft you can see the
connection in here
it also gives you rca input which when
you do not
uh on this thing there's trigger uh on
it so you can sequence this and power it
on that way which is nice
uh really nothing to complain about i
think it's just a very nice uh well
executed
excuse me design
going to the tear down this is a high
pec switching power supply i think it's
the 1200 so it's capable of putting 1200
watts out there and then these are the
two purify
modules you can see the benefit of class
d and surface mount devices and this
little module is a full amplifier
channel and so is this one so two of
them are used and then they're made up
to two what we call buffer boards or
preamp boards the gain of of the main
module is modest um so
in for most uses you need to amplify
that so companies use different uh input
boards there's one from hypex and
there's some expensive ones using very
exotic op-amps and stuff i've tested
those and they don't provide any
performance improvement you can screw up
the performance of this amp by doing a
poor job here and so that's why i keep
testing these amps even though the
fundamental purify module is the same in
all of them
very clean uh design over here as far as
layout and installation nice grounding
to the chassis where they set it off the
anodization in the aluminum
some companies don't do that and makes
that whole thing useless
nice shrink wrap around the high voltage
uh spade terminals here you can see them
in this nice power switch which feels
quite nice
so overall i you know i usually find
stuff to complain about on these
assemblies but i can't find anything
yeah if you're a nit picker you could
you could find something but in general
all the important stuff is done right
but the proof is in the pudding and
let's see how it performs so there are
three gain settings in here uh
which are called low medium and high
the
medium gain i really like because around
with four volts input it gives you
maximum power and just about every dac
that i measured modern dac that's well
designed has a 4 volt
output which makes quite well with this
most amplifiers still designed to the
old standards of needing very little
input so they lose some signal noise
ratio as i'll show in a second
so how does it perform let's step
through the gain settings at the highest
gain you only need quarter of a volt to
get five watts gain is about 25 26 db
it's a little low but again if you use
anything that i recommend there'll be
plenty of drive to push it to maximum
volume um
it produces a sign out of 105 db which
is a ratio of noise and distortion to
our signal
speaking of distortion look at how low
these are these two little spikes are
the only harmonics that i can see second
and third and there are minus 125 dp so
10 db lower than threshold of hearing
and then we have bit of power supply
noise in here which is uh
inconsequential so this performance
already is superb even at the highest
game if you knock down uh some gain and
go down to 20 db with a medium gain now
you need to put in almost half a volt to
get the same five watts and distortion
obviously doesn't change but the noise
will go down a little bit and so we gain
about 1 db of cyanide so
you know it's not much but heck you know
if your dad can produce 4 volts might as
well use it
and the lowest gain is way low so for
this you need pro interfaces that
output 10 or 12 volts or even some go as
17 18 volts so you need a pro interface
that
is able to drive this to the maximum
output and then if you did then you do
get a little bit more of a gain now the
sign that is up to
108.9 1.6 or about 109.
i plotted uh both of them in here and
you can see that you know they rank way
up here in our superb category if i zoom
into that so you don't have to look at
that eye chart you can see that the low
gain only loses to benchmark hb2 and the
high gain loses the topping and and on
benchmark the topping is much lower
power though and also a lot cheaper uh
than than the uh the uh audiophonics
amplifier but really i mean this is our
top 20 chart and you can see that just
you know amazing performance in here and
how the performance drops you know as we
go down here but interestingly enough if
you look down here other than tapping
and uh
benchmark i think just about everything
else is a hypex or bo5 based amplifiers
so uh quite an achievement uh in in this
thing as far as you know contributions
from bruno
and and hypex
um i chose to
measure dynamic range in just
low gain and
medium gain it gets crazy if i try to
test everything three ways so
in low gain it's just insanely good my
threshold for five was is 96 db and this
thing blows way past that by 20 db is
that quiet i mean if you have any kind
of noise in his issues in your twitter
when you stick your ear next to it this
amplifier will cure that and cure it
well and then at full power we're
talking 21 bits of dynamic range so
it's uh not a limitation your recording
will be the limitation before this
amplifier becomes the limitation on this
this is dac area category as far as
dynamic range and to achieve that in a
power device is
incredible um we got a medium gain we
really don't lose much to just you know
2 db we lose on signal noise ratio and
you know still 21 bits so
really don't don't fret over you know
that gain setting
so from here on i'm going to stick to
low gain why because both the benchmark
in here was also tested at low gain
which i think was 10 and 12 db and so is
the topping pa-5 which doesn't have a
gain setting but it defaults i think to
2012 db from memory so i thought it's
fair to stick with that from here on
with the low gain setting but you've
seen the difference this is just a
fantastic amp at
all gain settings
so we get again 21 bits of distortion
free range uh because i know if you look
at where the intermodulation distortions
are it's all less than one 120 120 is 20
bits so we're better than uh better than
that so very very nice
crosstalk is just incredibly low it's
the best i've seen not that you need
this much crosstalk but it's nice to
have i don't of course just because
they're two independent modules and
there's not much leakage between the uh
in a power supply from one to the other
uh this is this has been the thing
that's been was killing class the
amplifiers for a long time uh from being
a major contender in that their output
has ultrasonics in it that you have to
filter and that filter would interact
with the
speaker load and change the frequency
response so what frequency response you
got above a few kilohertz was load
dependent if you're building a subwoofer
with it doesn't matter you tune it that
way but if you're building a generic
amplifier for people to use that becomes
an issue a lot of the budget class d
amps that i test when i switch the load
from forum which is the classic
measurement to adopt you'll see that
also in adam there's ringing in there
some peaking
and the and or at four ohm there may be
drooping in here
with this purified module in this uh
audiophonics implementation you can see
the two graphs just identical they're
like landed right on top of each other
this app simply does not care what the
load is it maintains this frequency
response that's important because if you
got ringing with some speakers the amp
could sound bright or if it was rolled
off it could sound muffled so
now for most of us that are older you
know we don't hear that effect but you
know for younger growth uh definitely
definitely a major improvement in here
so that's very very well done
um
now we care about how much power we get
we may have clean amplifier but if it
runs out of power in the stores there's
no good and we get plenty of power in
here um so we see this graph in here and
yeah it gives up a little bit to the
benchmark benchmark it's just amazing as
far as
noise performance
and but the benchmark runs out of power
here at 163
164 watts whereas this uh
audiophonics am based on purify goes way
past the 255 watts so you get an extra
90 watts of power and that's super
important a lot of speakers these days
are made to and they're insensitive they
want to make them into smaller
enclosures that makes them cheaper to
build but also people don't want
gigantic speakers so the new sort of
last two decades the trend has been to
slim everything down you can see the
speakers oftentimes just the size of the
driver
and when you're making that small
efficiency is lost so you need a lot of
power you need a lot more power than you
think people assume if oh about a
bookshelf speaker i just need a 31 amp
no you actually need more power because
the floor sander has more volume in it
actually more efficient or has more
drivers is more efficient so this amount
of power comes in way handy on this now
you could bridge benchmark you get
double the power but it gets very
expensive as it is is more expensive
than this purify amplifier uh on this
but you know if you if you're operating
at the in this range and you want the
best of the best uh
is still the class leader there
this uh when i measure the power in here
that you see that i just talked about i
just put my cursor at the last
measurement point before it went nuts
and clipped but that's an imprecise
point um
we can actually measure at a very
precise point with respect to distortion
and a long time ago i picked one percent
distortion as that point and with one
percent distortion we get about 367
watts so quite healthy amount of power
and then i run this test where it sort
of is a burst that's where
98 percent of the time the signal's low
amplitude then also goes up and then
goes back down so if there is any extra
reserve power in the app we can get that
out
there's hardly any reserve power here
and that's because the switching power
supply in this is regulated and doesn't
have massive capacitors to provide any
kind of reserve for you so
what you see is what you get whereas a
classic uh class a b amplifier may give
you 20 30 40 50 more peak power
um switching to 8 ohm
noise floor is extremely low i've got to
compare to the
purify reference that i tested but i
think
after i post a review
i think that one was done at the higher
gain was not done at the lowest game in
gaining here so when i say beats the
reference design it probably doesn't but
certainly matching it is extremely good
it certainly gets the same amount of
power in here and it just lands you know
below this line which no the amplifier
has done since i made these graphs so
extremely good performance and uh
just amazing
now our measurement is is quite the
system that i've developed is quite good
at showing any weakness in any product
regardless of perfection and this is one
of those measurements that's pretty
brutal in that a lot of these tests
other than multi-tone are done at one
kilohertz
for this test i actually do my power
sweep same as what you see in here
although at forum and but i didn't step
through the frequency so i started 15
kilohertz go all the way down to 20
hertz so we can see at the extremes uh
and everything in between how the
amplifier performs we also have the one
kilohertz reference in here we see that
at higher frequencies the distortion
curve is not the perfection that we see
at at lower frequencies which is down
here and that's natural uh the gain
bandwidth product
goes down in the amplifier and his
feedback mechanism isn't able to work as
well as it does at
lower frequencies um
note that this measurement bandwidth is
45 kilohertz so the non-linearities that
i'm measuring are in ultrasounding
although you could argue that i could
run the same test as an intermodulation
test and and this non-linearity would
show up there without going to
ultrasonics but uh
you know this is just for your benefit
as first getting more insight but know
that you know their amplifiers are
measured where their best case scenario
is sort of a graph like this so the
incredible absence of noise let you see
this graph if this amplifier had more
noise all these curves would blend into
each other so but anyway just shows you
that we have very very precise
instrumentation to find any flaws
before i test any amplifier i power it
on and i watch it uh um basically thc
plus n or design ad and see what happens
to its noise and distortion
some amps vary like three four five db
but most of them don't vary a lot this
one does not vary at all it basically
goes from 105.0
to 104.9 after four minutes of testing
so i usually stop at this point saying
basically there's no change in
performance so don't leave this thing on
and if you don't need it you can just
turn it on and use it and turn it off
and be just as good
so
where are we with this thing it's just a
fantastic place this is an incredible
amplifier module that they're using and
they managed to
not screw it up build a good
implementation those of you who live in
france and you
can enjoy getting this product instead
of importing it from us
and
get the benefit of that a lot of times i
test stuff that's available in u.s but
trying to import it into europe is a big
problem
note that you can buy it in u.s also and
and import them uh you know obviously
have to worry about the shipping cost uh
there's no import duty that i've seen
from anything that i get audio wise
occasionally once in a while i get hit
by some kind of board duty but uh in us
it's this this kind of stuff is usually
exempt uh on this thing so
uh you know i i don't know about eu
prices but i've been told that if you
try to build this yourself you basically
can't do can't beat them or you know on
this thing because they get volume
discount of course on those uh modules
they're pretty expensive the purify and
hypex modules if you just buy one at a
time and of course you're not going to
get the pretty case and sort of built
and ready to go
on this now if you get some enjoyment in
building something like this go right
ahead but uh
you know if and i'm too lazy to go build
this thing so a fantastic product
fantastic implementation
and by the way audiophonics has a online
retailer has a stellar reputation
extremely easy to work with and you know
very very helpful my experience with
them has been superb from day one i
started the site they engaged with us
and uh
you know anything i i if i want to ask
them to send me x y z without hesitation
they send it to me knowing full well
that i'm going to measure it i've
measured stuff that doesn't well that
they sell they still link to the
measurements so people can see that you
know what the performance was uh
you know it's a company that cares about
getting the objective truth out there
and letting people decide uh on this
thing so i can't speak more highly about
audiophonics uh and of course this hba s
400 et amplifier okay hopefully you
enjoyed this video and see you in a
future one bye-bye